Before we go
we love to play a quick round of...
Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauds and cheers)
And, we have Julie Hansen here,
from our audience.
Hi Julie.
Hi.
(audience applauds)
So what's it gonna be, a Drewth or a Dare?
I have to go dare.
Ooh.
We love when it's a dare.
All right, we'll do anything, what is it?
Okay so, in honor of Texas Week,
Drew, I dare you to lasso Ross.
(Ross laughs)
Giddy up, cowgirl.
I've never lassoed before.
Me either, hello?
Can you do it?
Do I have a...
Is there a something?
Oh my God, there's a rope!
There's a rope here, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
But this feels like a very stiff rope.
Hold on, now.
I have to put on protective goggles
which I think is a,
not a bad idea, considering she's never done this before.
I don't get it.
In the cartoons they just "Woo, yee-hah" and...
Also like if you watch "Yellowstone",
does anyone watch "Yellowstone"?
Yeah woo!
(audience cheers)
God, I love that show so much.
I don't, but I just, I don't get it.
Do you see what I'm saying about this lasso?
I feel like I'm being set...
I need, I need something with more, like, give.
A drape.
This is...
What if you did it like a, like a,
like a jump rope and just (mock chokes)
and you pulled me in?
But look at this loop?
How I? What?
Oh, it goes behind.
There you go. Woo!
(audience applauds)
There you go.
All right, lady.
Perfect.
I'm not gonna look.
Right.
I'll be too scared.
(audience whoop and applaud)
Come on.
Wait, no, wait.
It's twisting.
Son of a...
God darn it.
Wow, good cowboy I'd make.
I know.
And they, Cowboys really,
they hook like running cattle.
I know,
they make it look so easy.
All right.
All right, come on lady.
Woo!
Get me. Get me.
I'm sorry, does this look like a lasso to anyone?
(audience laughs)
You got a limp lasso.
All right, ready?
Get me, get me, get me.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Oh my God!
You got one.
You got me.
(audience applauds)
Yes.
Listen.
People are only as good
as what they have to work with sometimes.
And oh, Rossy.
Yeah.
You hooked a big one.
I hooked a big old fish.
Aw, that was so fun.
Thank you for that challenge.
Yeah, we found another talent that Drew Barrymore has.
(bright music)